[Music]
a little disclaimer for the show as you
can probably hear i am a little sick tis
the season and it's also the season to
watch some great football games getting
close to the playoffs not if you're a
jets fan that's true it hasn't gotten
close in a long time if you're a jets
fan but
you grew up a jets fan and when i was a
kid i loved football so much but i loved
the la rams
i can't really tell you why exactly i
can why you love the costumes yeah i was
just setting you up i love their
uniforms they were so cool they had the
ram the swooping horn but i loved the
team and i thought there was a player
called eric dickerson this running back
who had all these cool things and he had
like goggles and a big mouth guard and
a neck thing he had all these like cool
accessories you know he just looked cool
you loved accessories i did i thought it
was cool he looked like um it was like a
star wars character almost and um
i think it was the 85 year i thought
they were doing really well
they were playing the bears and they
lost 30 to three the rams lost the bears
and i threw such a tantrum this is way
before i discovered meditation such a
tantrum that um i was forbidden from
watching the following week's games but
of course the following week was the
super bowl so yeah you were a maniac
they re-nagged on that and but you have
something to look forward to the jets
are playing later today and if you want
you can throw another tantrum when they
lose no no inevitably life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your slightly under the weather host
justin long life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my healthy
brother healthy as a horse yep why do
they say hello i don't know hmm horses
maybe they just tend to be healthy
i always think of jim carrey saying that
healthy is a horse not a drip
um maybe they do yeah because they're
very uh
they are they look healthy yeah they do
they have that great like musculature
and
yeah yeah we really loved football
growing up it was a fun time to watch
football too there was such fun play
like
it was like was that a golden era
probably joe montana and dan marino and
jono it was such cool players thinks
their error is the golden i guess so
yeah that's true there's always great
players right now it doesn't feel like a
golden era for the chats i know but
maybe you need to like jerry like our
like best friend of the show jerry maybe
you need to uh get another team maybe
it's time
that's not my style
how long do you wait do you wait your
whole life yeah really yeah because i've
committed i can't i can't i've been on
the stand for 40 years i'm not gonna
jump ship now i can't i just won't be
able to well jerry claims he did it uh
on the way that's his west coast team
the chargers
yeah well in fairness jerry does he
lives and has lived in l.a for oh yeah
that's true if i lived in l.a night and
he likes going to the live games i get
it why are we talking about football oh
yeah and the rams specifically
i'm sure i've told this story before but
i once wrote away to eric dickerson i
asked for his autograph he sent me one
back a really cool shot of him running
he
sent me a photo of that that said god
bless eric dickerson
and there was a comma but i didn't read
the comma i i just read it as god bless
eric dickerson i remember thinking like
well that's pretty
pretty arrogant
years later i realized he meant god
bless to me yes it's also not his place
to be bestowing god's blessings on me do
you know who another rams player was a
little later on who wasn't arrogant at
all i don't know was a man by the name
of kurt warner he was now in the
hall of fame a great story what i think
he was the only
walk-on was he the only walk-on player
who played in the super quarterback to
play in the super bowl not sure about
that undrafted but he became a legend
and he has a fascinating story and now
that fascinating story is captured
on film
in the lionsgate movie yes american
underdog yes starring
our guest oh whoa you just did you did
it thanks you you realized that i i'm oh
the guest is still yet to be so i wanted
you to say something okay
thank you that what a great setup his
our guest today yes you're right is zach
levi zachary levi zachary levi he goes
by zachary i think so people who don't
know him you know him oh i thought i
thought his professional name was zach
levi i don't think so zachary i think so
okay well that's your middle name my
middle name yeah christian zachary long
do you often do people call you zach
no so zachary levi is not only the star
of american underdog out now yes
lionsgate shout out to emilia people
also know roger from his work on chuck
the tv the hit tv show he was on chuck
and uh he was in the show in the movie
shazam that's right dc superhero in 2023
the sequel to shazam is coming out ooh
shazamer so uh i think it's fair to say
he's doing very well and we got him on
the show and so he's going to tell us
all about kurt warner because it really
is a such a great story it's a [ __ ]
fascinating story this kurt warner is
and he is by all accounts like you said
one of the nicest humble
he's a man of god who kurt warner yeah i
think they both are men of god i think
so but yeah we don't know for sure yet
but no because we haven't heard that
from sure that's true that's true
and why don't we do that why don't we
just hear from him i would love to so i
end this speculation on my part i would
love that okay here it is my ketchup
because i haven't seen him in a long
time and we were old friends back in the
day old acquaintances i should say here
it is my chat with shazams and chucks
and american underdogs zachary levi
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
oh hey hey
zach hi
uh you look how i look this is odd too
i'm in a hotel room so it's
strange lighting so am i this is this is
oh yeah two hotel rooms so we're making
it happen baby where where are you zach
i'm in l.a
oh okay why are you do you not live
there anymore
no i was here for like 15 years and then
yeah four
four four years ago i moved out to
austin uh bought uh property up there
yeah yeah good for you oh man that's i i
lived there briefly i lived there for
like six years i lived down now oh no
that's not a brief that's that's quite a
that's quite wet
well it felt brief because i was rarely
there i found my in fact i found myself
going there more often when i didn't
have a place there weirdly
it's expanding a little bit out there
people are right are people moving oh
man
like crazy in fact i'm i mean the irony
is that i moved out there four years ago
to build i my whole dream is i've wanted
to build like this independent film
studio kind of like a united artist like
a new united artists and oh wow and it's
also like a place where artists and the
light can live so it's got all the
accommodations so it's basically like a
studio slash arts commune slash resort
or whatever and i i thought awesome
would be the place to do it and i i
still feel like austin's a groovy place
to do it but the filming incentives have
been garbage in texas still but oklahoma
just passed incredible filming
incentives so i'm pivoting the whole
operation up to tulsa so now i you know
i've spent all this time in austin but
um
but i think it's gonna be a better move
to go and try and take advantage of all
of the all of the productions that are
gonna start coming into oklahoma like
they did in georgia you know yeah wait
wow wait so this is so ambitious that
it's it's a whole
company that it's you're going to be
doing productions there you're going to
be like yeah housing
wow
you explained that a little bit that is
the first time hearing of it yeah no no
totally totally i love
the job that we get to do i love being
an actor i've always loved it i love i
love our business to the extent that it
you know provides these spaces for us to
go do these things that we love but i
think that our business has been broken
far before we ever got involved in it
there's so many issues there's so many
things that i think are
antiquated things that need to be
updated things that need to be made more
humane
uh more more efficient so 20 plus years
ago when i started you know right around
the same time i think you and i both
kind of you know started similar yeah
before me i think is but anyway you know
yeah and all this time
i uh but you know 20 20 plus years ago
when i got my first look behind the
curtain and i saw how all the sausage
was made i was just so bummed i it i i
was like this could be so much better
and i don't know why people aren't
trying to make it better but i think
that's just because a lot of times
industries
they they you know they they kind of
they they think to themselves well if it
ain't broke you know don't fix it but
the question is well
well who is that who is it not broke for
and who's you before yeah yeah yeah what
was the first thing that you know i mean
what would you say is like on the top of
the list what struck you the most as
being
uh
not working well i mean look i always
kind of assumed that it was going to be
a bit inhumane because i had seen enough
true hollywood stories or movies about
hollywood and you hear about and see all
these you know
executives or things or producers and
all the ways that ways that people are
taking advantage of i was prepared for
that a bit
and and that still goes on i think
there's other things that i think are
even you know more inhumane specifically
like schedule i mean if you're working
on a single camera network television
show which by the way they're all kind
of disappearing well i mean there's
still a lot of them around but network
itself is obviously you know changing
drastically but yeah you know like i
worked on chuck for five years and
our first season we were shooting you
know 18-hour days sometimes like that's
not that's not good for the mental or
emotional health of your cast or your
crew or yeah therefore by the way not
good for the finished product i think if
you have you know happy bees make the
tastiest honey so if you're taking care
of people you're going to end up with a
better product to then go and sell and
make money doing so you know i'm i'm all
about that but one of the biggest things
was the creative
traffic jam meaning you know i'd be
working on these
multi-camera pilots even before i was
actually you know consistently working
i'd get a multi-camera yeah i remember
you were always i because it was you and
krazinski i remember there were like
guys in our group that were oh yeah
always doing pilot like
every year you get a pilot and
people people i think like with somebody
like you or with john it was like oh the
office was there you know they they just
hit it they just struck it or like you
got chuck you know but like i i don't
think a lot of people realize that years
before chuck it was
pounding the pavement and it was like a
success but it's it's that weird success
right where it's like
you're you get the pilot and then it
rarely doesn't get picked up so you did
a lot of that i know yeah well you know
i did i there there were two i did two
multi-camera pilots those first couple
of pilots they didn't go i almost gave
up in the business i was like oh well
this is it yeah clearly not yeah like i
had my shot i had an agent who was like
listen listen the fact that you're even
booking a pilot is
head and shoulders above what a lot of
other folks are getting right now so
take that as a sign of of you know of
confidence but at any rate so even in
just you know prior to less than perfect
but even just doing these pilots i was
made privy to this creative problem
which is that a lot of executives a lot
of network executives and studio
executives
they go and woo these writers and then
the writer's like great cool and they go
write the show and then immediately
these executives are like right so
here's all the things of course
we're going to need you to change and i
remember saying i was you know i was
nobody i was this 19 year old kid
sitting on the sidelines and being like
what the [ __ ] is this why
why is this the way this works shouldn't
isn't the idea like look you know the
best producers
are the men and women who are able to
identify great talent
yeah and foster that talent and bring
that talent together and not get in the
way of that you know every once in a
while there might be a thing of like hey
you know what might be
this might be a good tweak or that might
be a good tweak but they're by and large
they allow
the auteurs the artists or whatever to
go and create and the more
executives i find the more executives
get into that mix and it's not to say
there's not some great executives that
don't have some great ideas but i do
think that that's the exception and not
the rule unfortunately and i and that's
what made me really want to go and
create a system that was less about that
more about the artists more literally
what chaplin and fairbanks and mary
pickford and their pictures
do way the hell back in the day which is
now by the way we're we're not like you
know just over the hundred year mark of
when they did that which is really crazy
to think about i know i know my my
grandmother passed away in february and
i think about that sometimes like she
would talk about not too long ago going
to movies with those stars and the
silent movie movie stars um what but
what what how do you do that then i mean
it's like an amazing idea and it's
uh
but how do you enact that zach well i
mean i i you know
i don't know slowly but surely really i
i cause you're right i started
interrupting i i noticed that just from
having a little experience in the
network writing space where you're right
they'll say yes we like your id we like
what you've done and then it's it's
through a series of um
uh notes that it just gets diluted and
uh into whatever the
and it's by a panel of people who aren't
necessarily creative at all
um but they have they they all have to
justify their jobs you know so they'll
um insert creative ideas that end up
just yeah diluting the product i i yeah
i have experience in that i don't know
if people are aware i think that's why
you see how things have changed
creatively too in the last
20 30 years like the movies aren't what
they used to be
no no and also look i think in some ways
i think you know streamers have
have helped in that
a lot of the streamers i mean at least
you know now they're all staffed up with
a lot of the executives that were at
these studios in these networks but you
know there there's so much content being
made and there's not there are no
executives to even really you know
a lot of those projects can be left
alone
like i felt that about white lotus i
don't know if you saw white lotus oh my
god it was so good oh it was so good but
it struck me as like a singular vision
of mike white's you know where yeah it
didn't i i didn't feel the hand that
network hand in it like um
that was hbo right that was yeah
yeah yeah hbo has always been good about
this in fact continues to be i think one
of the best about it they understood
that mission forever ago they understood
that
back in the day when cable was was you
know just starting to kick off it was
kind of like what happened with the
internet nobody really knew what to do
with this extra bandwidth everybody knew
there was this new bandwidth and we got
to grab it up and everybody got their
own cable channel you know disney but
they were just filling the time with old
like i remember disney channel when
there wasn't original programming and it
was just all the stuff from the vault
and i mean myself just watch that yeah
religiously or hbo
they were constantly putting on movies
like there were so many bee movies that
never did well in the theaters but
that's right
for hbo to buy aftermarket which is why
by the way like clue for example which
is i'm sure probably a a yeah a huge
favorite of mine our generation
made that movie lovable because it
bombed in the box office our generation
did not like that movie and therefore
hbo was able to buy it and then they put
it
over and over and over and our little
minds were like this is so great
so it's it's really interesting how all
that stuff has evolved but hbo i do feel
like has always
fury
caged fury what was cage fury um it was
a female empowerment movie about a a
group of women who were imprisoned for
various crimes and they had to sort out
their differences in prison eric
i believe he tried to break one of them
out of prison but you know they they had
romantic relationships in prison it was
uh yeah case fury it was mostly romantic
relationships that they had yeah it was
the original orange is the new black is
what you're saying yes yes it didn't
have as much social commentary
necessarily but um it was yeah it to my
11 year old mind 12 year old mind it was
quite you know it was erotic oh yeah it
was it was a meaningful yeah
totally yeah but there was a thank you
another
another random movie that i bring up
with people often but most people don't
remember but it was playing uh ad
nauseam on hbo was this movie called
whitewater summer and it was um
it was um
um uh sean astin and
kevin bacon
and basically sean assin played this
like kind of troubled youth and
his parents sent him away on this like
summer camp to go do ropes courses and
mountain climbing and stuff but kevin
bacon was like their hard-nosed like
camp counselor and was making people
what was it called
white water summer go go go watch it
it's it's a classic bro it's a classic
okay wait i didn't do well in theaters
and then ended up on hbo
but all those but yeah
hbo they i think that they are very good
at allowing the artistic process to be
as unimpeded as possible mike white is
somebody that you know you don't want to
touch that just let mike do what he's
doing that's true and it's so yeah i
mean that that is one of the better
shows i've seen in a long time
i can't stop thinking about well i just
wanna i wanna send kevin bacon a message
this might be fun
uh about whitewater summer hold on once
kevin i'm on the podcast and we're
talking about a movie called whitewater
summer
please send me a response about your
thoughts about whitewater summer
whitewater summer
okay this is great see now i'm only two
degrees away from kevin this i love this
this is fantastic yeah
have you
levi do people get that wrong in line
yeah but but i mean that's totally
understandable levi's cheese
yeah yeah and levi is actually my middle
name my last name is pew people
that's right welsh yeah yeah yeah but
why did you leave has been my acting man
why'd you drop the pew is it too is it
were people saying pug
well yeah it was a mis it was a lot of
mispronunciation but um no i mean
honestly man it was a very like when i
was a kid i was relentlessly teased
about it i mean i i was bullied for so
many reasons you know not the least
really that i was this spazzy actor
nerdy kid who loved video games and
rollerblading and whatever i mean i was
a target for bullying
i mean you know like stinky pew like all
the things kids come up with right so
that and that's one thing i mean by the
way florence pew has been rocking it so
i'm glad that she's got bigger balls
than me she was like [ __ ] this i'm going
in
i haven't heard that i mean it's such a
juvenile word like it's been a while
since i've heard someone use
you oh you yeah
you
yeah my agent when i started in the
business she didn't tell me hey you have
to change your name but she said hey
listen every time i make a call on your
behalf there's always a comment it's not
always necessarily derogatory but people
are always like oh that's interesting or
different or blah blah blah
and oh i knew and i knew enough at the
moment you know like at 18 or not yeah
18 we are the product right we're not
going door-to-door and selling vacuums
we're going door-to-door and we're
selling ourselves and so to the extent
that i could help shape whatever this
product was to make it a little more
palatable or sellable or whatever you
know and i do and i spent a lot of time
vacillating because i really didn't want
to bend or change for hollywood i was
like i i need to remain who i am if i'm
going to keep doing this journey but
then i thought about it and i prayed
about it i talked to my family about it
and at the end of the day i thought you
know if i just dropped the last name
zachary levi still my name i'm just
augmenting it a little bit never in a
million years did i think that that was
going to
then
give everyone the idea that i was jewish
which by the way is not a problem at all
i'm an honorary member of the tribe i've
i've read the child's role at seder
multiple times but
yeah it's fascinating how people's minds
you know because levi's is quite a quite
a you know it's a hebrew my parents got
all of my in mind and my sisters out of
the bible and so it's you know it's
obviously very hebrew but like
roles in the beginning of my career i
lost some roles because i went in and
auditioned and then
the writers by the way writers and who
and producers who were jewish calling my
jewish agent saying yeah you know we
love them little too jewy for the role
and she's like what what what i like
your reenactment of the jewish producer
yeah you know he's good you know
you know yeah yeah that's ironic and my
jewish agent was like what are you
saying he's a [ __ ] from ventura
california like what are you doing so it
is
interesting yeah so i believe i like to
change but there are there's levys and
levies and i mean there's so many so i
don't i don't take any offense in it
zach when you say like you prayed about
it that specifically i always wondered
this when you pray about a specific
thing
how do you find that and how does that
answer come to you in the form of
the deity that you're praying to yeah no
it's a valid question i would imagine
everybody's got different ideas or
answers to
that type of a question in my in my case
i really believe it's always trying to
find peace
so yeah we'll be struggling with
something we're vacillating on something
we're weighing something
and i do think that you know prayer
it part and parcel to meditation to
manifestation to
trying to
understand who you are and where you're
at a little bit better and and i and i
do believe in a higher power and i do
believe that we can tap into that higher
power and the collective wisdom that is
within that higher power and i and i'm
always just trying to find the peace in
all of it right so i'll spend that time
i'll be praying i'll be thankful you're
not anxious any longer you're not
uncertain exactly and sometimes you know
and oftentimes that reveals itself again
like in all that prayer
and thought i found myself
recognizing again things we just talked
about like well i am the product in my
own mind in the time at 18. it was i was
like what's weird and what's not and and
how do i find that and so ultimately
through all that prayer and thought i
found it all kind of settled down into
okay well i have a piece i don't feel
like i'm i don't feel like i'm changing
myself bending over for hollywood i
don't feel like i'm sacrificing a part
of who i am i think i'm making uh look
logical you know rational decision and
i'm still me and all of that kind of
peace i felt that peace in it and so
that's what i got
hey jonah hill feldstein became
jonah hill
um
it's uh i i i never understood why
people would
you know struggle with that some names
are harder to say some names are uh i i
never understood when people are
offended by getting a name wrong or i've
never i guess i've never had that much
of an attachment to to my name you know
well yours is also phonetically very
easy to do
i guess so i don't know a lot of people
that are gonna
how do you pronounce that there's also a
lot of people who have to change their
name in some way shape or form because
when they're trying to get into sag
there's someone with their name already
there what there was yeah probably told
the story it was another justin long
there was and he was a he had done
mostly adult films but there was um but
he had a single uh
credit a single like legit credit like
like a late night cinemax movie um and
so he he was eligible what was
taft-hartley he was eligible to get uh
in the union but
he had yet to do it um so so there's so
i was playing around with having to use
maybe my middle initial or something uh
but anyway it's boring but he ended up
not joining so i was able to take justin
long but yeah he's a porn star named
justin long
an adult actor um fantastic exactly
branding yourself this is now really
interesting to me because you are one of
the few people i know who
are and i don't want to labor this point
but you brought up that you do have to
be aware of how to sell yourself and
brand yourself and all of that um
was it difficult you for you being
because you are a christian actor you're
not just not jewish as you said you are
you're a christian and you're a person
of faith was has that been difficult to
to talk about because it's something
that it that i think for a lot of
factors would be you know there's
there's um there's a stigma attached to
that like it or not um i don't think
there should be but there happens to be
has that been something you've struggled
with
yeah well uh you're not wrong i mean
there definitely is in a town that is
comprised of so many
progressive
you know seemingly progressive
open-minded folks there there can be a
very interesting
rub or pushback of like oh you're you
know you're a person of faith or
whatever that is and look and by the way
i am a christian i would put it in
quotes only because i think that
christian as a term is
so massive like there's so many
different interpretations of what
totally i know personal interpretations
and stuff but i've never felt like i've
had to
shy away from who i am do i feel like
i've had to
be wise about who i'm talking to and
what i'm talking about and
uh for sure but the truth is i mean you
kind of have to do that with a lot of
things i think i think a lot of uh
really hardcore
uh like
heart hardcore conservative christians
um
who are very very religious like i'm not
religious at all i'm very deeply
spiritual um and i do take a lot of
wisdom particularly when it comes to how
we ought to treat each other and how we
ought to love each other and love god
and and how we ought to communicate that
stuff i absolutely kind of extract from
scripture but there's a lot of stuff in
that that i don't ultimately agree with
or i have very different opinions that
most than a lot of other actual like
hardcore conservative christians yeah
life is a is always a balance of trying
to be wise about you know what who is
your audience and making sure that
you're not well i think there are a lot
of part again very you know line-drawn
christians that get they can be very
obtuse sometimes and they can that and
that they can lead to their own
struggles because they're trying to beat
people over the head with some message
that people aren't wanting to hear
[Music]
i came home after being away for about
two weeks
and i noticed a few changes one of which
was that you christian your skin looked
clear and nice now don't get paranoid it
wasn't bad before but it was i'm glad
you noticed it you had a glow i've been
told that by other people as well now
why might that be i've been using
curology it's a whole system right it's
a skincare system well i would say it's
a game-changing skin care system is that
i think that's fair to say because i'm
glowing i know you are i do have a glow
and it's so it's made for you for each
individual by a dermatology provider and
they create a custom prescription cream
for your specific goals whether that's
tackling acne or
clogged pores skin texture dark spots
fine lines or something else you fill
out a questionnaire you talk about your
skin you send in some pictures of what
you look like pretty simple
questionnaire i just got my products
back because and it's like you said it's
all based on your specific skin type so
i'm excited to dive into it can you take
a picture of your face yeah i i'm now
more excited because i see the results
right in front of me um so what did you
say like because i get a little um i i
notice i get a little shiny on the nose
my t-zone my t you don't both have two
zone issues uh yeah that's one of my
issues too and i'm a 40 year old man now
but i still have breakups occasionally
but i i'm looking at you right now i
don't see any shine on your nose and
there's a there's really unflattering
lighting shining down on top of you so
get started with curology just like i
did with a free 30-day trial at
curology.com
long just pay five dollars for shipping
and handling that's c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash long to start your free
30-day trial cancel any time
prescription subject to consultation i
don't want to brag but i love my smile
what i don't love is all the toxic
ingredients in most dental care products
they're not good for my health or my
teeth i want the best for my oral health
products made with natural ingredients
that help my smile and not harm it and
that's why i use lumino lumino makes
toothpaste mouthwash and whitening
products that actually help your oral
health instead of hurting it they use
purposeful and uncompromising
ingredients like sea salt aloe coconut
oils to better clean and brighten your
smile plus
everything they make is certified
non-toxic everything they make is
dentist formulated backed by over 50
studies and proven to protect the good
bacteria in your smile also known as the
microbiome i've been really enjoying all
the products there's
something really satisfying knowing that
it's all non-toxic and once you start
using these products you'll realize that
most dental products that you've used
before are toxic and artificial tasting
and just psychologically i
am so gratified knowing that what i'm
putting in my mouth is good for me it's
really a great company i love how my
smile feels and looks and i know you'll
love lumino as much as i do too
get fifteen percent off your order today
by going to get lumino dot com slash
long and use code long that's g e t
l u m
dot com slash long code long to save
fifteen percent
getlumino.com
long
hello hello
[Music]
you're so good in this movie uh american
underdog but kurt warner strikes me as
somebody like that like he he i know he
is a christian and he seems to really
walk the walk you know in a humble way
in a way that never
seems to shove his religion down
anyone's throat was that is that an
accurate perception that's purely my
perception of him no no you're you're
wrong
you're not wrong you're you're yeah that
is uh
no he's very aggressive he's very high
he's an incredible
oh no he won't shut up about it you know
interestingly though i i think that i
started in a place i'm sure i was i was
a more conservative or had you know
stronger lines about do this or don't do
that you know when you're coming into
any
idea of what your faith is supposed to
be and you have people that are telling
you what that's supposed to be as a
younger person that can definitely
take hold but the older i've gotten the
more i've been able to have perspective
and question things and yeah what i
think is actually true in all of it and
i think the same could be said of kurt
and brenda you know they'll even tell
you you know when he was going through
his journey of
winning this super bowl and all of this
incredible cinderella story
he was much more tim tebow back then he
would you know every every after every
interview was like hey you know first
and foremost i've just got to thank my
lord and savior jesus christ in some
ways that's beautiful i mean obviously
it resonated with me as a 19 year old
kid and i was you know seeing this and i
was of faith as well but i i think that
he and brenda as they've gotten older
and more mature in their faith have
recognized that that's not even
necessarily the thing that you need to
do in order to represent your faith or
to represent god you can do it in a in a
way that is a i don't know that's a
little less
so direct in that and more about
how are you carrying yourself what are
you exactly how do you treat people not
to you know go too far down into a
tangent of my criticisms of the modern
church but you know of all the people of
all the religions it is christians who
claim to
really believe in this concept of how
much god loves us and how we ought to
love one another and
very specifically in scripture it talks
about to in christ talking about love
your enemy and pray for your persecutor
i mean these are very huge concepts that
you know prior to then i don't think
anybody was even thinking about like you
don't love your enemy that guy's trying
to kill you you got to defend yourself
you got to kill them back i mean that's
how it works yeah it was really radical
thinking yeah it was super radical
i don't find
most well i don't find most people to do
this but the people that are touting it
the hardest i don't find a lot of
christians that that really do that i
think that
and again i don't expect people who
don't follow jesus to do that because
they're not saying that they believe
that but christians by of all people
should at least be going listen
we can't be hating these other people
they're they're they're god's children
they're loved but i i don't see a lot of
it i know i know nor do i zach and i
never understood that because you're
right that is the fundamental tenet of
the faith is to love thy neighbor is to
turn the other cheeks it's all
predicated on it
so i know i know it confounds me too um
but i i give you a lot of credit i
always have for being um
not necessarily even outspoken but
carrying yourself with that in mind with
that kind of mentality and um
i think it takes a little bit of
fortitude to maintain any kind of like
faith in
our business yeah
this industry is fueled by a lot of
things and faith is not typically one of
them you know yes it's and again and i'm
not even to indict you know the entire
industry even though i'm trying to
recreate it but i i do
but i but but i do think that um
hollywood is is an industry and it's
operating and unfortunately you know in
this capitalism run rampant world that
we're in we find ourselves where we are
and that's why i think it's probably
very difficult for people to embrace
concepts like faith when they're
operating in ways that are very contrary
to what faith would bring about which is
more empathy more humanity caring about
people caring about the environment you
know these are all things
that are they kind of run and you know
in contrast to unfortunately so i don't
think it's very very valued zach are
there movies in tulsa that this um
this thing you're putting together are
there is there a certain type of movie
that you're hoping to make or just
movies of all different types of is it
just a way to empower the filmmaker yeah
how cool yeah no i want i want to do
everything i i look tulsa just happens
to be the destination
because i was in texas and felt like
sisyphus pushing a boulder up a hill
for four years trying to figure out how
to make this crazy dream a reality and
you know the pandemic screwed things up
obviously in what i was trying to do
there but again
you know
to me this was i i try to find where
god's fingerprints are and i go where am
what am i supposed to do and how am i
supposed to do that and all of a sudden
under the ashes of the pandemic
where all of my jobs i had these great
jobs lined up and i was ready to go do
these jobs and then all that got you
know i'm sure you're you and all of us
we all got like flatline and we're all
sitting around going okay what are we
doing now yeah no i know but that's
that's when um american underdog came to
you right or came back that's exactly
right yeah so i always thought of you
zach as like the prototype for kurt
warner when i heard sometimes you hear
about casting things and you're like huh
but this was one of the ones where it's
like yeah of course zach is like
perfect to play back i mean i mean in
every way but also like it's rare to
find an actor who's just as physically
meets meets those like physical
standards kurt warner is a huge guy
um was that part intimate i mean like
obviously you had the size and all that
and the chops but the idea of throwing
like him i mean you had to look like him
in every way was that oh yeah that that
yeah no well listen i mean
i mean yeah i love you both we're about
tallest largest white guys who can grow
some stubble and both you know
share a similar similarity
yeah
he's got this like warm but intense look
he's got a very specific like and you do
it in the movie yeah it said look it's a
stare do you know what i mean maybe you
were doing it subconsciously it felt
like you were channeling him with your
look you have he has a look his eyes do
something yeah he is you know you that's
actually a pretty good summation though
he is he's super chill but he is he can
be super intense he really yes he really
looks when he pours into his football he
pours into his football when he pours
into his family he pours into his family
like he's yeah he he really gives a lot
but he is a quite a chill laid-back kind
of guy um but dude listen man i i i grew
up playing sports here and there but i
did not go playing football so i did not
grow up i i know how to throw a baseball
real well but i never really learned how
to throw a spiral and
really good spiral consistently you know
like with anything to be excellent at it
it's repetition and repetition and
repetition and repetition now hopefully
you're rep you start these repetitions
when you're in like middle school
yeah and and you really get it down i
was starting to try and learn how to
throw a perfect spiral at 40. oh man
that is re like the amount of
repetitions like by the time we even got
to shooting the actual football stuff my
right arm my right shoulder already had
tendonitis oh my god
i bet but you have his you it looks like
he personally trained you because you
have his form too you you you hold it
like him
we we i looked at a lot of tape i had a
great quarterback coach this this guy
named clint dolezell who also played
college played arena at the same time
that kirk played oh wow and also made it
into the nfl and he was great and also i
got to throw around with curt a good bit
too curt and brenda were on set almost
half the movie so we got to spend a good
amount of time uh and
i got to got to spend a good amount of
time with them during that and and kurt
definitely helped me you know with you
know mechanics and trying to you know
and and we were always staying on top of
particularly like you know how does he
drop back you know three step drop yeah
because that was just you know for a
while right it was too long of a drop
back like he was he was stuck in the
pocket for a long time sometimes yeah
when he well so so yeah when he was
transitioned to arena ball yeah that was
one of the that was one of the because
arena moves so fast oh that's right
right he wasn't used to it but here's
here's one of the coolest things about
the story to me and i think it's i think
it's something that's very
i don't know i think energetically
spiritually philosophically true which
is
we have these dreams right we have these
these these goals and we focus on them
so hard and we want it and we want it
and we want it
and oftentimes we are focusing so hard
on the thing that because of that almost
like an unhealthy fixation that we have
on it yeah it eludes us we can't really
grab it because we're not in the right
place our heart and mind are not in the
right place in order to receive whatever
that blessing is whatever that next
chapter is we're not prepared for it
because we haven't done the inner work
necessary instead of doing the inner
work we're doing the outer work and why
am i not getting this thing well
kurt found himself in that position
he you know
was playing college ball got a shot with
the packers didn't happen then he's
running around doing nothing trying to
figure out how do i get back into this
arena ball he thought was well that's
where the guys who don't get into the
nfl circled the drain like why would i
want to go do that and then after
stalking shelves for a while realize
well going and playing arena ball at
least is throwing a ball and that's a
better life
and so going and playing arena ball
it made him
a faster quarterback and faster than the
play happened in the nfl so the nfl was
interesting the defenses the defenses
weren't up to they didn't move as fast
as you had to move in arena so all of a
sudden here comes this law you know long
in tooth rookie that nobody even gives a
chance but he learned a skill that
nobody in the nfl oh that's so
interesting because
right yeah yeah and he had time for the
wilderness yeah
and and and he had those guys he had
isaac bruce and tory holt those guys he
had incredible receivers but i didn't
know that i didn't know that the arena
ball prepared him in that way for that
yeah totally that so that prepared him
but also
it was but it was also uh uh his
relationship with brenda you know all of
a sudden he had hit with brenda and her
kids who he immediately fell in love
with uh
that all galvanized very quickly and
amazingly and also
he had something that was deeper and
more important to value and to look at
and find identity in and once he's real
yes exactly and once again once he let
go you know just
relax not let go of the dream but relax
this death grip on how do i make it
happen and instead was looking at these
other things in his life that brought
value and and worth and love well yeah
lo and behold all of a sudden the this
this dream starts to reveal itself more
and avail itself to him and so i think
there's something a good lesson and
something to learn about that yeah
to divorce yourself maybe from the
outcome you know of wanting this thing
of wanting an outcome for something
getting all of your and pinning all of
your worth and identity yeah to that for
sure for sure i'm dying to ask about
curb your enthusiasm which i rewatched
your stuff uh you're you're my my
brother and i might do the show we talk
a lot about um of course we love the
show but there's such a clear difference
uh between the actors on that show who
are
just committing to the reality of the
scenes and those who are trying to be
funny and it kills me when when
you know actors go on and they try to be
funny because first of all you can't
really out funny larry david but you are
such a good example on that show of the
former of somebody who was just
really in the scene and not trying to be
funny um and and it ends up being so
much fun here uh
what was your experience like with him
what was it like it was so cool man i
mean i was again i was i was still
pretty new i mean i was doing less than
perfect at the time
um yeah but this audition comes up
it was down at um
i'm sure you know like down on olympic
you know lantana center or whatever like
that you know those all the all those
yes all those offices and yeah and i
remember going they gave me this little
fortune cookie sized piece of paper that
says this is who you are and this is
what your objective is in the scene oh
my god that's it that's how you go and
then i and i go try and walk down these
hallways trying to find a private spot
where i can just start riffing and
trying out ideas so they called me into
the room and i by the way i had no idea
i was about to step into the room and
larry was there larry did
i was like this is crazy so i stepped in
and jeff garland was there i think and
and we just go in and and i'm like hi
you know mr david you know here's your
room here's the windows here's the
remote here's you know just over over
explaining the room trying to get a tip
and that's what it was and then i got
the job and yeah and then and then you
know it was one day
well it's a good lesson for actors it's
probably for the best that you didn't
have that time to to prepare to like
think of funny things or think of like
you know come up with bits to do because
you were just present you you allowed
yourself to just yeah present no
absolutely yeah yeah you know like when
we get into our heads and start second
second guessing all of our choices and
like does that work and really totally
what are they looking for more than
anything they're looking for somebody
who's confident in the choice that they
make it might be the wrong choice but if
they're comp if we're confident yeah it
goes a long way somebody who's just
listening to larry and responding which
you did so well um i do want to play
because kevin wrote back so i want to
hear his thoughts really quick if you
don't mind
uh go for it okay let's see i have not
heard this well we just kept trying and
trying and trying to
make that movie better um
and uh i remember we were chasing the
white water because we were running out
of
summer
so we ended up uh at one point and yeah
he sounds so cool
somewhere in ontario then i land in new
zealand that's funny but that wasn't the
end of my going to play uh
bad guys in on white water oh yeah uh
because i ended up doing river wild yeah
with carroll street
and uh another bad guy in the rapids
um
a little bit more successful than that
one
that's amazing
and and and river wilds with meryl
streep yes and yeah strathern right
right oh so good and john so good
yes yes so he what that's funny you
should go watch white water you should
go i want to uh white water summer
because it's it's a trip man like i want
to now he's great in it he's great i had
no idea he shot that in new zealand
that's fantastic well isn't it wild that
is a funny story where like uh one part
of the shot he's in ontario and then he
lands in another part of the shot in new
zealand that's cool um yeah
it'll be magic baby that's the movies uh
speaking movie magic shazam
are we getting a sequel oh yeah you're
filming the sequel now right no we
already shot it uh oh you shot it we
shot it in atlanta this summer yeah so
it's all in the can they're doing all
the posts on it now
and uh it comes out june of 2023.
um
we gotta wait a little while okay i i
but as for the first one zach i i was um
i was so curious if you were inspired by
tom hanks's chair because it felt like
that you it felt like tom hanks and big
uh did you was that a big inspiration
for you you're to be that childhood yeah
yeah yeah totally i mean it's still my
favorite movie big is still one of my
favorite movies i
i think penny marshall was it was a
genius i mean you know what what she
gave us and that in a league of their
own and i mean she was so good as an
actress as a director as everything but
big was
so delightful and i remember as a kid i
remember thinking because i i knew i
wanted to be an actor since i was a kid
and i remember even then thinking what a
fun like how fun would this role be that
you you're an adult but you get to
pretend like you're still a kid and tom
is so good and he was so good in the in
the role so was his little sidekick that
red-headed kid he was he was great
well that's the joy i find when i'm
around kids now is like you get to kind
of act like that you get to kind of be
a kid it's the best um
wait yeah you mentioned
yeah i mean i yeah suzanne was basically
just superman meets big and
yeah
i mean it's such a dreamy role i i i i
love
it's kind of such a just a big kid still
inside so it's uh yeah easy transition
in a lot of ways but really just getting
to allow that to amplify and and then
the second one we had even more fun than
the first one i think it's i think
people will enjoy it even more than the
first one but also putting on all that
muscle putting on all that weight was
that difficult was that did that just
require constant gym time and eating and
what is that yeah yeah yeah i mean i i i
uh
you know i was always i was hovered
around 200-ish pounds you know healthy
or not like my body was kind of
maintained
uh i had never ever tried to just do a
hardcore like let's put on massive
muscle and so
uh it was the first time i'd ever done
that and in two months i put on like 20
pounds
and that it was a lot and it's not
always by the way the healthiest thing
either like if you have more time to put
that that weight on that's a much better
yeah right but
i mean i was eating i was eating
something like you know close to four to
five thousand calories a day and working
out five days five days a week and
it was intense man but it was cool i
mean it was cool to see what my body was
capable of i've since you know i since
the second movie uh i had to hold onto
my weight and put it back on for the
second movie and i've now allowed myself
to drop a lot of it because i don't want
to eat that much all day
well you can work out five days a week
but if you don't eat all those calories
you want people you have to
right what what is the best what is the
thing that you found was the best way
the food item that was like the best
thing to put on the way
just cheeseburgers um
no no no no it's gonna be healthy you
have to eat pretty clean oh oh like
chicken breasts look if you if i could
eat five thousand calories if i could
eat five thousand calories anything
cherries and out bro i would be stoked
i wouldn't be stoked but you got to eat
super healthy you got like clean protein
and vegetables and occasionally you'll
throw carbohydrates in that but
oftentimes you're not it just depends on
where you're at in your load and like
you know are you are you doing heavy
lifting are you doing a cardio day are
you there's a lot involved things that i
still am not very you know clear on
unfortunately there are people much
smarter than me who do these things that
guide me through the process but
um
but it was it was you know look i love
the channel i love i love the as actors
we get to jump into roles and learn
things and do new things that things
that challenge us in ways that you know
learning in other languages through a
football new talent from kurt warner
yeah throwing up
round if you don't mind i know you're
we're running out of time
okay all right also have you run into
any of those bullies that you used to
pick on you for being like a lanky actor
after now you're this you're a superhero
now
you know i i i have seen people uh i
have seen people uh in my hometown of
ventura uh
they're like what's up buddy
yeah they're like hey man like congrats
hey listen man i was thinking like i
might want to get into acting i was like
oh yeah is that right um yeah uh but you
know i don't know i mean
that was actually
that was actually one of the things that
i think um
i could sense my growth as an individual
when yes i remember being in high school
feeling like i'm gonna show these one
day i know i know i remember getting to
a point where i
i
yeah but and i remember getting to a
point i recognized
before even you know seeing these guys
again i remember recognizing like if i'm
doing this just despite someone else's i
know for the wrong reason and i really
had to let go of a lot of that anger so
by the time i then ran back into them in
my hometown i wasn't angry with them
anymore in fact i kind of felt a lot of
pity for them a lot of these guys who
never left their hometown they haven't
right they haven't been able to
experience a lot of other things in life
so i know i've seen men i wish them well
isn't that funny zach i know that might
be something that that might be a common
thing that people think uh oh you must
you must relish running into people that
tease you or picked on you but i i know
what you mean there's at a certain point
you let those things go and now it just
feels uh
really childish to participate in that
stuff it feels like but at the time
i also know that feeling of like one day
i'm going to show you you know
yeah and by the way and it was part of
what drove me that is part of what
drives you and that you can get you up
into a place and like rev you up there
and help you you know help you keep
going after something so i appreciate
what it offered me in that moment but
it's certainly but it's you know
unforgiveness is drinking drinking
poison and hoping the other person dies
and i i don't yeah i never want to be
doing that yeah i i agree well said life
could be a dream
[Music]
hey life is short listeners business
wars is a podcast from wondering that
brings you the full stories behind some
of the biggest business battles in
history in their new season you'll hear
about the fight between espn versus fox
sports to dominate the sports television
industry espn is the american cable
network that plays the trail for around
the clock sports coverage athletes even
change the way they play just to get on
sportscenter's nightly highlight reels
but right around the corner rupert
murdoch's fox sports channel started
gaining on espn in the us the sports tv
business is worth more than 12 billion
dollars the question is who will come
out on top fox sports or espn listen to
business wars espn versus fox sports on
apple podcast amazon music or you can
listen one week early and add free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app hey life is short listeners
wonderees even the rich podcast is doing
a two-part series on the bizarre and
fascinating kidnapping of paddy hurst
and you won't want to miss it
one night in 1974 19 year old college
student patti hurst who happened to be
the heir to the hearst newspaper fortune
was kidnapped from her berkeley
apartment she was kept in a closet for
weeks while her captors made their
demands then after two months in
captivity and a completely unexpected
twist patty announced that her name was
tanya and was seen on video robbing a
bank with her captors the new season of
even the rich explores different
theories about what actually happened to
patty was she brainwashed or was she the
victim of stockholm syndrome listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app
[Music]
what's your go-to emojis oh favorite
emoji oh yeah
you know i i'm gonna be honest when when
when people first started emojiing i was
so irritated i hated it yeah me too not
even
actually like like actually like i'm
talking about like first emojis like
actual titles
yeah exactly yeah friends who would do
that i was like
what are you a 15 year old girl like
what are you doing but i didn't realize
i didn't realize that what it does is it
allows us to have a little more context
and nuance to the text and so totally it
creates a tone super emoji it sets its
own someone's just saying hey i'll see
you there in minutes which could be kurt
or it could be like oh yeah angry or
whatever by the way which none of us
should be assuming anyway but because
we're humans and because we go through
these things and so i love being able to
throw a little thing at the end of a
sentence just saying and this is how i
feel about what i'm saying just so you
don't misunder you know misinterpret
well that's why i love the kissy the
blowing the kiss face because it's it's
always positive it's always like yeah
you're right if there's a risk of it
sounding hurt or like short tempered
it's no here we i love i love you yeah
we're good we're good yeah we're good
but i do love i love i love the uh
fingernail polish that's a favorite one
to me that's just saying i'm a sassy
[ __ ] i'm a sassy [ __ ] and i'm making
things happen and i and i'm a big fan of
the salsa dancer salsa dancer yes yes
yeah up there having fun hey hey let's
go hang out and boom we're gonna go
dance yes i like that um who is your
i'm sassy [ __ ] who you are a sassy
[ __ ]
zach uh
who was your first celebrity crush
oh
man there were so many uh you know okay
well if you can maybe get a little brock
kelly lebron
yep
in fact to this day i don't know if
anybody has really surpassed her
stunningness in weird science
i got god man guys so jealous of those
guys that they got i know that movie
and then and then seagal got to marry
her like what did
oh i didn't know that oh is that true oh
i think so i'm pretty sure that that
kelly lebrock married steven seagal for
a hot season
yikes uh it's funny because there was a
couple degrees of separation you talked
about kevin bacon uh i used to love adam
baldwin was one of my favorites um my
bodyguard and chris make peace from
weird science and now adam baldwin is in
the kurt warner movie with you
yeah yeah yeah but it's great because
adam adam and i did chuck together for
five years and so
yeah so this was a fun little easter egg
for all the chuck fans that we got to
bring him back in
cool oh he's one of my favorites i i
always loved him um okay uh kelly lebron
great answer what is your favorite ice
cream flavor
uh cookies and cream
easy huh
it's it's
a classic it's simple yeah it's just i
don't and here's the thing i don't
really like oreos by themselves even
dipping them in milk they're very dry
i'm not a fan but you crunch those
things up and you mix it up with some
vanilla ice cream and damn it man if
that's not one of the greatest things
i've ever created and i don't know i
know the one thing that bothers me and
must not to you is the texture of the
the cookies when they're in the cream
they're never all that oh the ice cream
pad they're never all that crunchy
but you don't hate them yeah i get that
it depends on how
how big the pieces are like sometimes
you go and get like a
cookies and cream like flurry or or yes
that's true whatever there's slightly
larger treasured chunks that are in it
so you can get some of that but yes
that's a good point i need the crunch as
much as i just want that taste there's
something about that taste that just i
don't and i and i'm sure part of it is
just like neuroplasticity and me you
know being a 10 year old again and going
to basketball robins with my family and
being like totally black isn't great yes
yeah that accounts for a lot i think um
yeah but it's a classic for a reason
you're right uh what what is your
favorite holiday zack
um you know
i don't know to be perfectly honest i
actually had a conversation about this
last night with a friend i find holidays
by and large to be so
unfortunately uh i feel like they've
been hijacked by consumerism materialism
and not christmas
[Laughter]
not not my favorite holiday black friday
yeah
but but i would say i will say look i i
love i love the uh the the
i love the heart of almost every holiday
i love that it's supposed to remind us
of something that's important and
beautiful thanks you know giving thanks
being generous uh being proud of our
country and patriotic yeah remembering
those who have died for our country or
those who are still serving it
the past you know presidents who have
done so much good in the world like all
of those things i think are beautiful i
just find it really unfortunate that we
somehow it feels like
that we almost save up all of our thanks
for the one day we save up i know i know
i know one day
i know i'm sorry
you're good you're good
you're good you're good
so so that's why i would i have a hard
time but but i but i do i mean look man
christmas time there's something really
lovely about just the vibes and if
people are in a good place
and uh i do love uh good fourth of july
barbecue and some fireworks yes you know
yes um that's good
what is an acclaimed movie that you're
embarrassed to admit you haven't seen
you know one of those ones that people
shame you for you haven't seen blah oh
man so much
i guess dirty dancing a lot you have
never
see i'm about to go okay
wow
well you should definitely see dirty
dancing i know also there's a really
cool series on netflix called the movies
i saw that isn't that funny i saw you
you've seen that about dancing but yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so but
dirty dancing really is a great little
flick man yeah
and jennifer gray they're they're i know
mine are less about well okay i haven't
seen the shining okay give me crap about
that all the time okay oh so funny i was
just engaged in a conversation about
this uh an instagram conversation if you
can count out that um so you haven't
seen it so this won't spoil anything you
know what it will spoil something um but
i would just say
that jack the guy's complaint was that
jack nicholson is crazy from the get-go
he is
wild with his son right away and that's
a comment then all these people were
like it's a common complaint um
obviously worth seeing i'm not going to
shame you for it oh i'm definitely going
to see it yeah
and it's not all the time at like the
arclight or
anymore but but like you know um
i know i know i'm sorry i know i wanted
man if i had the cash i had a bought
cineramadome at the very least just to
keep that i know
it's just such a bummer and now like in
cafe 101 is gone like all the time i
know
i know i know
i know i know what won't you take uh
what is it what is a game show that a
pastor president you'd want to be on a
contestant
there was a game show back in the day
called press your luck it was whammies
no enemies no ways bro i was so addicted
to that as a kid i would love to do a
modern day pressure like oh that's a
great call um do you drink coffee or tea
and if so how do you take it
uh i drink both but i'm more of a coffee
guy and i take it black
black cool okay if you could learn
another language what would it be
well i mean i should probably dedicate
to the spanish that i've been trying to
learn for my entire me
me too since the pandemic i've been
trying to learn spanish it's not saying
i'm duolingo it's not taken dual legal
is good uh rosetta stone's also good i
mean honestly the best way to learn any
language is just go immerse yourself in
a place i know what we need to do is
just move down to costa rica for a
summer i know family and just really get
into it yeah how cool would that be um
if you uh what is your favorite cereal
zach
um you know our mom never our mom was
like pretty like a crunchy granola even
like yeah back in like the late 70s
early 80s so
we never had sugared cereal the sugary
we got was like honey nut cheerios yes
too but it didn't ru i liked it because
now i don't like i'm not addicted to
sugar like a lot of other people like we
never had sugared soda we had hansons
like natural oh yes
yes
when you when you drink soda now isn't
it great isn't it like shocking how
sweet oh it's a lot it's a lot like i i
i see i see people go like constantly
just drinking coke and stuff oh it's
wild there's so much sugar in there i
know uh if you had to choose a different
first name what would it be
um
i've never even really thought about
that probably something like well you
know what you know i will say this my
entire life i don't know if you've ever
had this but i have these moments where
people people that i've known
very shortly or people that i've known
for a really long time they have this
moment where like they're they're kind
of an other thought and they're they're
talking to me and then they're like hey
um you know hey josh i mean zack oh yes
oh interesting josh i've been called
josh specifically oh you you you look
like a judge well there you go so i
guess
my
animal josh yeah i i can see that i
again but i get a lot of jason's i i've
gotten i've gotten josh before and i
never care i'm never like um yeah you
know
insulted um
my dad my dad always says he goes uh
call me whatever you want just don't
call me late for supper so that's yeah
yeah classic
what is his name
daryl
oh daryl that's a good old-fashioned
name uh if you had a sandwich named
after you the um
the the zack levi or the josh levi what
would be on it what would it be josh
that's the curb your enthusiasm the
joshua levi
um yeah uh what would it be it would be
it would be um
oh man i don't know
the the the z zack
the spectacular the the spectacular oh
no sorry i meant i meant zach what would
actually be on it what would it be
comprised oh oh thank you
oh man i just love like i just love like
a good classic like throw some turkey on
there with some turkey with some
provolone mustard mayo lettuce tomato
avocado
deuces i'm happy cool okay any type of
bread i don't know like uh like a little
toasted like whole grain but like good
whole grain not that beautiful grain
that they said whole grain but it's not
really whole grain okay
i do love a good sourdough okay that
sounds delicious uh what is your
favorite tom hanks movie forrest gump
yeah but that's hard to do that's but
it's very i mean like i love so many his
movies i know it's hard but i do think
forrest gump was one of the most
pivotal movies i've ever seen in my life
i just yeah he played a character that
was so
um pure and i think it's an example of
how we all ought to treat each other you
know like uh no matter how much he was
ridiculed no matter how much people
um shamed him and and and made fun of
him or
didn't understand him
he never ever ever ever once
lost any amount of love for those people
and yeah i think through most of the
movie oh it's because he's unaware but
until he gets to the point where he
meets up with jenny in modern day and
she's got little forest and he is
looking at little forest and he looks at
her and starts crying and says is he
like me and you realize as an audience
member for the first time this guy's not
he's aware of how he's aware yes
love and he is still not guile he
there's no guile there's no deceit
there's only just positivity and i meant
i was 13 years old when i saw that movie
and i could not stop crying i know but
the whole movie i cried
it was insane i was like i want him to
be real i want this person i want all of
us
i want to hug him your rep is asking us
to wrap it up these are just quick uh
yes or no would you rather uh take a
time machine to the past or the future
your rep is gonna get mad at you now uh
now whatever that's fine uh
uh uh uh uh uh uh
the past pass okay are you more of a
talker or a texter talker
okay uh night of night or morning person
night
uh beach or mountains would you rather
live in
visit beach yes uh toilet roll over or
under over there is no this is not i
agree but a lot of people think it's
under i know but i've heard a lot of
hundreds okay now finish the sentence
please zach life is short so so love
yourself and love others
well said uh i am so sorry i've taken
advantage of your time
it is so good i'll see you again
so good to see you too it's been a long
time man it's been a long time but i'm
i'm i've always rooted for you and i'm
so happy for your success you're [ __ ]
great in this movie uh you're it's
always good to see you and i'm i'm glad
we got to do this back at you man bless
you bless you so good to see you
hopefully all right we'll cross again
sooner rather than later i hope so i
hope to be at your place in tulsa austin
wherever it's bro come let's go make
moves again i would love that it's what
an incredible idea yeah i'm rooting for
you thanks man all right
thanks for having me
so that just happened that just happened
kind of um very sincere he has a real
energy like self-assuredness very he has
a lot of energy he does yeah and um i
like it and he has like so much
enthusiasm for what he's saying and
passion for what he's saying that
i can see that
why he was such a great choice for
shazam because that character oh was
like he talked about
very similar to tom hanks's character
and big yeah very childlike where they
maintain a child like enthusiasm yes he
really does have that i think he's
always had that um
yeah whenever i would run into him i'd
see him at you know we'd see each other
at auditions and we were on that actress
circuit uh he was always hey yeah oh
he's up
seemed always up yeah and um a good
choice too for kurt warner because he
really i was looking at him and like
he really does look like him he's got
his bill you made that very clear
yeah you were like but your face yeah
he's got something about you there is
there is it's it's uh the way his face
is structured it's a really good choice
for kurt warner um carol warner might be
a little bit more your suit a little bit
more swarthy
they're not the same person
no i'm just trying to examine the
differences because that's how similar
they are physically to me yeah yeah it'd
be great to get kurt warner on the show
too yeah
um but his performance yes not only does
he happen to look like him which is you
can't really compliment someone for no
that's true a chance resemblance that's
true
but he really captures something he
captures his essence i think but they
have a similar essence too both men of
god neither of them are preachy
no about being men of god which i think
is like you said to him admirable i i
like that i like that he um he lets his
actions speak for themselves it's also
something about christians and you guys
touched on this that i think a lot of
christians like very hardcore christians
give christianity a bad name in a way
like any hardcore i guess so yeah and
we've talked about this
a little bit before but like there's
something kind of undeniably positive
about the things that jesus christ said
right so if you are like
a christian who's not particularly
religious but follows
his teachings
yeah it's kind of hard to argue against
it it's like i know treat other people i
know well and you know be kind and yeah
forgive or give i mean those are all
good things yeah i know it's yeah it's
hard you're right it's hard to argue
against the like fundamental tenets
of it and you can argue against the
veracity of
all the things that happened you know
like rising from the dead and all but
it's hard to argue with the things that
he said yeah it's i guess it's easy to
argue against the veracity of some of
the more some might say it's easy you
might say it's easy yeah but believers
might not say it's easy
right um i i think they i think
believers might i don't want to um
uh christians explain
you know believers how they feel but
like i i think it's i've heard people
say that like faith is not easy it's
still hard
you know it's that it's hard to like
accept to to walk through life believing
that a man rose from the dead
after three days do you think it's
harder to be a believer or a believer um
i think it's harder to be a believer
but not by much because well now it's
easier much easier to be a believer
because
he really got himself together he got
himself together he's got um
he's in a nice he seems much more stable
now
so it's easier to believe in what he's
doing
now but he's grown up a lot yes he was a
kid he was a kid but wasn't he like
peeing in buckets at hotels and he was
doing some wild [ __ ] yeah so it was i i
imagine back then it was much more
difficult to be a believer well he found
god too oh the belieber became a
believer that's
right
so maybe that went a long way for him i
bet i i i i believe you're right
uh that was a great kevin bacon cameo oh
yes
zachary didn't seem all that
impressed by the cameo i think he got a
chuckle out of it he had a he had a
chuckle
he had a clever line he said now i'm
only two degrees oh yeah that was funny
yeah but also in zachary's defense kevin
bacon's explanation of this movie that
zachary was touting was a little
underwhelming you know it's just like
yeah like i i i thought it was cool it
was cool of course it was cool
be careful about what you say
don't tread lightly don't put words in
my mouth about kevin bacon of course it
was cool but it was a little less
flattering about that movie oh right
than zachary had been about oh you're
right he had been touting so he was like
yeah i remember that one we had to do
like a reshoot but i ended up making a
much better white water
right years later but i think zachary's
enthusiasm for it had more to do with
nostalgia and i'm sure you're right he
had been touting it quite uh
enthusiastically and what was that movie
you said that eric estrada movie cage
fury yeah yeah he hadn't seen that one
no i'm surprised i'm surprised i thought
all um
christian men of god boys of god he was
a boy of god yeah i was a boy of god at
the time when i saw it would it do for
you well it was one of those things that
inspired me to
maybe
maybe not be a man of god i see do you
know what i'm saying i smell what you're
stepping in
i think it's very cool what his his huge
plans yes i know make another united
artist that's i know extremely ambitious
but he seems like someone who has so
much energy
and compassion drive
that i feel like if anyone can make that
happen
yeah maybe he can he's like the kurt
warner of actors
you know he's a bit like the current
word of actors he can on his own push
something like that and like maybe tyler
perry did it yes i know in atlanta
it's true why not it's a cool idea i
feel like now more than ever to do
something that's more conducive to like
creative freedom and and like safety
yeah and all of that let me ask you
something do you think one of the
goals of his of this new studio he wants
to create is to make more christian
content movies of god i wondered i
wondered because i don't know how to ask
that i wondered because there is that
genre like a huge genre like kurt
cameron oh those christian movies uh
kevin sorbo yeah them it's it's i think
they like
really you know in fact we shot our
movie in tampa they make a lot of them
there the hallmark movies yeah i didn't
really get that from him i i wondered
but i didn't get that because uh he did
say he's like i want to make all types
of movies here all types of things yeah
i know and i think if he wanted to make
a specifically christian job of god i
think he would have said that yeah i was
watching a movie about christmas at
graceland and um
you know like you said a lot of these
hallmark movies do have funding from men
and women of god there was a moment in
the movie where um the woman who's
taking care of these three kids gets
them an advent calendar
the kids are like maybe 15
12 and seven you know they're kind of
like the missed out fire age characters
and they go
almost in unison an advent calendar yay
i used to like advent calendars yeah
those are funks every day you open up a
little door i know
well this one was cool reading well this
one you open up little uh boxes the
little like drawer like like actual
little pull out drawers
oh really yeah like little file cool
yeah i've always liked diving calendars
really yeah it brings me happy memories
oh yeah well these kids were psyched
about it i should see that movie yeah
christmas at graceland uh i think the
new short
the lightning round the new short
questions oh you liked them i think they
went well what name would would you want
to be is i kind of like that i know you
like it but i suspect that almost
everyone is going to be like i've never
thought about that well
i i maybe not i don't know but he does
he had a good answer for it
josh
and as you were saying
how you look like a josh i was thinking
he looks like a josh he does yeah both
everything he looks good josh but he
does yeah i don't know why but he does i
know he'd want to be on press your luck
um a show from the past no whammy no
whammy no oh yeah yeah uh but little
does he know it's coming back it's not
coming back it's back oh it's on now
elizabeth banks is the host oh so he
could be on it he could be on it huh
i agreed with him about the cookies and
cream that oh yeah i don't need a
crunchy cookie in my cookie no i don't
either in fact uh in fact i kind of
prefer it when it's not where it's kind
of that like soft soft dense cookie yeah
i don't know if it was the day before
the day after
i probably it was the day before i would
have said something to zachary but um
i had them in in
las cruces new mexico the most delicious
it like really made me rethink where
cookies and cream is on my channel it is
delicious yeah there's a reason it's so
popular oh man it was so
good and so
creamy it was
it was oh man
i love that big wasn't his favorite tom
hanks movie after he talked about how
how much he loved pigs well what was it
again
yeah yeah i bet i suspect that's going
to be a
very popular choice yes somebody else
said forrest gump by the way
thank you again to all the people all
the shorties on the facebook page
who um suggested these great questions i
know they're all they're all from them i
know thank you shorty it was uh there
was so many to choose from you did our
job for us and uh it took a long time to
call through all of them yeah in fact um
yeah the tom hanks one is great because
uh well we i shouldn't say this but we
just said jojo siwa on and hers was
immediately philadelphia you're lying
don't get people excited that she's
gonna be on by the way it would be great
to have her on yeah yeah she was the
runner-up and dancing with the stars i
just watched the whole season of dancing
oh that's right that's i'm like i'm like
a dancer i don't get that it's not fair
i know
well we could talk about that god who
knew you were so like anti-jojo siwa i'm
not i'm not no no siwa
um
no i'm not i just think like i saw that
one episode i saw the final episode with
you and it's like yeah she was great on
it she's amazing but she's a dancer
let's read a lot i thought the whole
point of that show was like it is but
there's a lot of basketball there's a
lot of crossover would you say the same
thing about a gymnast who was on that
show or would you say the same thing
about an actor who's been in some
broadway musicals who had to do
something like amanda klutz yeah there's
there are there's a lot of carryover you
know yeah that's true because most
actors have had to do some dancing i i
would also say i think and athletes
athletes are they move really well they
move really well so nobody's different
it's like athletes don't
that's different i think athletes i
would allow on the show and
you're right amanda klutz that was
borderline because she was like a dancer
on broadway there's a lot my point is
there's a lot of borderline contestants
they should get people who are like
supreme court justices or like people
who have no dan nothing to do with
dancing
first of all you'll never get any of
them and second of all if you do
the ratings would plummet you think oh i
think i would watch it you would watch
it who is the most which justice is the
most likely to go on oh that's a good
question clarence thomas no no no no um
i would say or maybe one of the younger
ones like um
brett kavanaugh maybe it'll rehabilitate
it won't be a conservative um
i would say probably um
so i would say elena kagan elena kagan
that's my guess yeah like i'd like to
see pat sajak on it i'd like to see pat
sajak doing i know i'd like to see pat
sagic on this show yeah all right let's
read a letter okay
from meredith berg subject high from
newton mass
hi justin and christian so cool to
recently hear dan harris being from
newton and of course
justin's own link to newton
i've
i've lived here in newton for about 13
years with my family and i've been an
avid listener of your podcast for the
past couple of years does it really say
that yes well i talked about it on the
show what's your link
i can't believe you don't remember this
i don't the lady i lost my virginity too
it's from newton oh
really yes
i talk about it on the day oh my god
we talked about it you know i'm glad i
don't remember that well i'm not i'm
sort of like insulted you want me to
have to keep that kind of stuff in my
brain maybe not your sexual exploits
back to meredith berg
it's interesting to hear your debate
about the boston accent and people who
live here i personally don't know anyone
who has much of an accent but i'm a few
years younger than dan same age as
justin i think and i did not grow up
here newton tends to draw a lot of
families who look for a more diverse
community than some of our neighboring
towns and of course great schools our
educators are among the best in the
nation it was a real newton bragg i
think it's that newton has so many
people who live here from all over the
u.s and world and that's likely why the
classic new england accent is generally
disappearing that makes sense
thank you meredith newton tends to draw
a lot of professors and company
executives because boston has so many
colleges and large companies based here
and as justin knows we are only 10 to 15
minutes from boston so it's very
convenient place to live does she work
for the travel bureau of newton mass wow
i actually didn't know it was that close
to boston um the lady that i knew
from newton um i knew her in uh
poughkeepsie new york
so not nearly as impressive of a city ah
no but i missed out but i have good
feelings about poughkeepsie so thanks
for
sharing um back to meredith possibly our
most famous person of the moment who
lives here would be dr ash
the brown university school of public
health doctor who has been all over the
news lately often on cnn i obviously
haven't been watching the news lately
he's a newton parent and was
instrumental i believe in getting newton
kids back in the classroom this past
fall which us parents truly appreciate
we also have ties to john krasinski matt
damon matt leblanc and beach a novag wow
krazynski of course former competitor of
zac zachary yes he was a competitor i
don't want to make them sound like
adversaries no but they they were they
went up for the same stuff yeah
i'm sure there are many other celebs i'm
forgetting who grew up here anyway just
wanted to say hello and that i was happy
to hear you know of newton a little bit
really enjoy the show i feel like
justin's interviewing skills have really
improved over the last few years and i
love that oh thanks meredith but then of
course that makes me and my
early interviews were trash yes that's
how i think of it um former journalist
here oh former journalist who she's in
terms well i get justin's one-time
premise that he didn't want to over
research people there's a lot to be said
for not looking like an ass
when someone mentions something that
they're currently working on that's
likely public knowledge and they might
feel a little bummed you didn't at least
take a few minutes to look up
she's right she's not wrong no
no well
shamed
um my point being i think just has
gotten better with time and i applaud
him thank you meredith he's very
inquisitive and i love how he pushes
people from more of the background than
just the simple answer people tend to
give because it's easier these are
really these are really skills you learn
by doing and it makes for such a more
interesting show oh okay well
take care can't wait for more i try to
offer a fun would you rather except my
mind is only full of home renovation
related ideas and they all kind of suck
because we're in the midst of completing
a renovation and it's highly stressful
wow that's a bummer
like would you rather oh okay she does
kind of offer one like would you rather
not have a working fridge or dishwasher
but have a working stove
or would you rather not have heat but
have work working hot water wait wait
can you repeat the first one i think
she's doing this to illustrate how she's
the home renovations she's yeah but
let's try to do it okay would you rather
not have a working fridge or dishwasher
but have a working stove
working fridge or dishwasher not have a
working fridge yeah
or dishwasher but have a working stove
um
oh that's a tough one fridge would be
tough uh
a dishwasher i definitely go without i
often don't use the dishwasher
i like to wash dishes by hand i would
rather have the working fridge
than a stove yeah then you just start
eating more raw stuff ooh raw or healthy
it's healthy you grill
yeah grow more yeah me too um or would
you rather not have heat but have
working hot water
poof i would rather have working hot
water yeah it's winter now stay clean
bundle up yeah i think she said these
are incredibly lame clearly but based on
lived experience i don't think they're
that way no i think everyone can relate
to that thank you meredith now meredith
a little advice for you i don't second
guess yourself yeah that's those are
your experiences now and they came from
a real place uh and thanks for writing
in meredith yes what a letter and uh
thanks for the um
the kind words uh she's a former
journalist so that i take those to heart
and if you guys would like to write in
to the show our email address is life is
short at wondery.com
and thanks to our great guest zachary
levi thanks zachary i've always been um
sorry to interrupt i've always been
really confused about how to say his
last name and now i'm glad i know for
certain well because i i made a little
stumble just now no during the interview
when i was like
levi you did yeah uh meredith might not
appreciate that but um but i did i was
honest about it because i've never known
how to say it now you know yeah uh levi
the jeans perfect yes and thanks to uh
and she mentioned den so thanks to
meredith and everyone from newton dan
harris and all the people who grew up
there and um and go uh check out his
movie american underdog lionsgate is has
released it and it's it's out everywhere
you can find it on all the platforms and
uh and check out um
all of his other stuff chuck and
shazam coming out and and see what he
makes at the studio in tulsa yes zachary
yeah good luck to him uh good luck to
him and uh we'll talk to you guys next
week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long and it's also produced by
megan v monaco and katie v allen senior
producers michelle
lans audio engineer sergio enriquez and
there's an executive producer his name
is marshall louis we like saying his
name yeah it is a fun name to say you
know what else we like working for
laundry
bye everyone
[Music]
favorite city
new york
biggest pet peeve uh
people rubbing their hands together
uh
what's what song would you want played
at your funeral
um
uh backstreet's back
um
if you had to choose a different first
name what would it be
um
chairs
if you could give
your 18 year old self one piece of
advice will it be um
uh there's a lot of fish in the sea
christian
christian favorite favorite tom hanks
movie
the sleepless in seattle
you